[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pleine lune a une influence sur nous
vrai ou faux
c'est faux sur les marais oui sur
l'humain non et justement un argument
qui revient souvent c'est que si la lune
est capable d'avoir une influence sur
bada océan en entier à doit très
certainement voir une influence sur de
tout petits humains
c'est vrai que quand la lune est pleine
à cause de son alignement avec la terre
et le soleil les marées sont plus forte
parce que l'attraction gravitationnelle
de la lune se combinent à celle du
soleil pour cirer plus fort sur l'eau
des océans est ce que ce serait pas
logique que c'est aussi une influence
sur nous parce qu'on ait fait un bonne
partie des noms l'attraction que la lune
exerce sur nous est insignifiante
parce que la gravité oui c'est une force
qui existe et qui s'exerce entre tous
les objets qui ont une masse mais c'est
une force qui diminue considérablement
avec la distance pour vous dire à quel
point
l'attraction gravitationnelle de la lune
sur nous est insignifiante une moche qui
se posent sur nous tire plus fort sur
l'autre notre corps que la lune la
question d' influence la lune sur nous
en a quand même fait l'objet de
plusieurs études sérieuses et ces études
là dans la vaste majorité des cas ont
rien trouvé de très concluant qu'il
s'agisse de l' influence de la lune sur
les accouchements la criminalité les
accidents ou les tentatives de suicide
la santé mentale
les surdoses de drogue ouais tout ça est
étudiée il ya quelques études isolé qui
pourrait porter à croire que bel et bien
un effet mais souvent ces études leur
repose sur une méthodologie douteuse
elles vont mettre de côté des variables
assez importante et souvent les
résultats sont même pas reproduit par
d'autres études ensuite aussi même si de
rares études ont mis une corrélation en
évidence c'est loin de vouloir dire
qu'il ya un lien de cause à effet par
exemple pensez vous que si vous mangez
de la crème glacée
vous courez un plus grand risque de vous
noyer que si vous ne mangez pas de crème
glacée et n'ont pourtant on pourrait
fort probablement démontré qu'une
augmentation de la consommation
c est liée à une augmentation du nombre
de noyades
alors que dans les faits oui les deux
augmente parce que la température
augmente on n'a plus envie de manger de
la crème glacée quand il fait chaud et
on n'a plus envie d'aller se baigner
quand il fait chaud mais ça veut pas
dire que la consommation de crème glacée
provoque des noyades
peut-être qu'en ce moment même des
infirmières ou des policiers se disent
que vos ya plus d'accouchements les huit
plaignants plus de crème les nuits de
pleine lune et qui sont les mieux placés
pour le savoir mais ça se pourrait
qu'ils aient une mémoire sélective qui
fait qu'on a tendance à se souvenir des
événements hors du commun quand ils
surviennent un soir de pleine lune mais
que si ces mêmes événements surviennent
un autre soit on le remarque pas ou
encore comme tient pas compte des
nombreux soir de pleine lune sans
histoire